hello everyone if you think that
building a community from ground zero is
very easy it is not it is the most
difficult part and spatially if you are
not backed with the brand name I have
been there I have seen that the pain
because most of the companies and people
prefer to support the companies which
are backed by the brand names little bit
about me my name is Neha Sharma I'm a
full-stack developer and from India
I am the organizer of chess lovers
meetup group one disclaimer I will be
using the meetup and committee word as
interchangeable because my plant my own
committees on meetup.com so sometime I
say meet up sometime I say community and
I am an accidental speaker how I will
share that too this is my twitter
handler if you want to follow and see my
take tweets my committee tweets you can
I started my journey with my community
jazz lovers which is JavaScript lovers
three years back and after that I
started living in this dense thing
happened to you when they are unplanned
mostly because jazz lovers were not so
planned but I started doing and most
awesome thing happened to him with to me
sorry before that this is my team aprox
five years back as you can see I am the
only female I was having two troubles at
that time I moved to a senior level at
that time and I was not able to see lot
of females at the senior role I was not
able to get a mentor for myself in my
city the second problem was V all
developers in my city we were more
focused towards our job we were not into
collaboration we are not into sharing we
our focus is only our job Monday to
Friday 9:00 to 5:00 apart from that we
were not interested in anything and I
started actually saying these things
learn something new every day for
yourself just not for your company not
for your job just for yourself
so what I did so I was just going around
looking for mentors looking for senior
females in tech field and I was not able
to get single female in tech industry in
my city so I was just talking to one of
my colleague I knew about meetup.com
platform and I'll just bounce the idea
would you be interested in sharing our
knowledge with the other people who are
new in this IT world and my colleague
was like yeah I can do it because he was
a trained speaker so I said ok on the
same day in the evening sitting in a
cafe I filled my meter page
I picked this domain and my event was up
and my journey from a developer to
community builder started so we were 2
members we were having one chapter zero
sponsor and no experience of running our
community I was having no idea that how
I am going to do it but after three
years here we are now we have done
oh sorry technical glitch sorry so after
three years this is the stats we have
done more than 55 meetups in just in my
city we have more than three chapters in
India in Delhi itself we have 2700
members out of that 85% people are very
active and we have 25 plus sponsors and
not only this we are the first community
who become the part of the Google
developer program in take from Delhi and
we are the first most active committee
from India to be the part of that
program so yes it was a very big
achievement for us but was it easy
not at all I was having a full-time job
I was having although I am not married
but I have my parents whom I have to you
know I live with them the culture of
India is very different so my first
trouble started with my family when I
told them that this is what I am trying
to do my pic my father's reaction was I
told you become a teacher after
schooling but you were like that no you
want to study computers and everything
now you have a stable job you are
earning a good now you want to teach
people free of cost by paying for the
venue and everything by your pocket you
are stupid and I was like no now it's
not like that it is not teacher
teacher's job it is like mentoring and
helping others and from there my fight
with my family started and every weekend
when I am stepping out of my home fall
doing my Meetup
I used to have a big fight with my
family why you are doing this this is
waste of time if they are not able to
understand or not even my family my
friends were also used to make joke of
me so many of my friends stopped
following me on Facebook because my
whole feed was full of the meetups tech
stuff and everything and I was like okay
whatever so today in the morning when I
was
entered in conference area I actually
tweeted I'm sorry I will be shamelessly
filling your feeds with the J s concrete
so beer with it
so my first trouble was that but I
didn't gave up because I knew what I am
doing and I was very focused so what
worked how we reach to this level know
your tribe you need to know that in
which city you are running your
committee you need to understand the
culture so in Delhi if you are doing any
Meetup
or any event during Vitas it will never
ever work only on weekends people come
out of their home to attend any event
and for that you need to do lot of a lot
of hard work apart from that you need to
know your members and your tech industry
so when I started cheers lovers at that
time angular one just launched so people
were just running behind angular they
were having no idea that if they need to
also learn JavaScript there were few
developers who came to me and asked me
that
should we just learn angular and
frameworks or is it important to learn
JavaScript at that moment I decided to
do the first meetup on JavaScript only
no frame were nothing and that actually
helped me a lot because there were a lot
of people who just started their career
by a framework and they were no idea
about the basics so whenever you are
starting something please know your city
your culture your crime logistic I was
ready for the events I was ready for the
meter but my city was not there was not
a single place available in my city
where I can have 30 people with wife and
projector I actually struggled two
months to get a venue and I ended up
having my first meetup at a cafe which
was at a party zone and I was like what
and that was not even the close tour
venue so whenever we were doing we were
doing coding lot of people were just
coming in and asking can we get the
table and we used to say that oh sorry
this is a closed tour event today we are
closed so it was very troubling but
before that the most trouble in trouble
part of that venue
my parents used to think that I'm lying
because on weekend I am going to such a
party happening place so they used to
assume that I am just going out to you
know have fun with my friends as a
result I have to spend extra money to
record whole sessions to take the
pictures and go back and show my parents
see I'm not partying I'm actually doing
something relevant so this is how the
logistics were very tricky there and
with the speakers also for a whole one
year we were not able to get a outsider
speakers reason we were not a brand name
developers used to come they used to
love it like it but they were hesitant
to come on the stage and share their
knowledge so no worries I become an
accidental speaker because of that
because I started giving the sessions
there but now the after three years I
have so many speakers sending their
slides requesting but now I don't have
the time to you know bring every speaker
on the stage so this is how I never give
up when I was not able to get a speaker
I took that responsibility I learn stuff
I stand on the stage I gave the session
so logic is very important you need to
work on the logistic the first venue
although it was a very at a very funny
place but the best part is it was very
accessible by the public transport
because I am a female I am organizing I
know the pain of every female who is
travelling on weekend to particular
venue tele is not a transports friendly
space so the first point become as a
female when I was organizing I was
already taking care of these things by
myself
committee this is the most funny part
because when I decided to start Meetup I
was preparing myself that lot of people
will be asking tech questions but nope
no one was aware of what is meetup what
is for me and people was just filling my
messages with what are you trying to do
they were not able to understand that
why a girl if on every weekend doing
free meetups sharing her knowledge and
not charging anything is she trying to
send something is she going to hire
instead of company behind it and I was
like no my friend this is the me this is
the essence of a community this is a
community by the developer for the
developers I know the pain when I was
looking for mentors and I was not able
to get that's why I'm standing here
helping you out so that in future you
will go out and you will help others but
for most of the people it was a alien
stuff and I was getting random questions
around it and the one of the question
which I used to get regularly was what
you do on meetups because getting a
person from our online platform to
offline event is very tricky you need to
gain the trust and spatially developers
are very hesitant they feel very shy
that how we will go to a random place
sit with random people whom I am going
to talk so whatever it is I got tired of
answering this question I went ahead I
wrote a blog medium block are they at
year service meter I mentioned each and
everything that how I start planning on
meetup how I do the research of the
topics how I open the registration form
when you are coming on the day of the
meetup you will find someone welcoming
you they will give you the name tags and
how this whole session will go what kind
of food we will serve and after the
meetup is done how we do the follow-ups
and I put a lot of photos and a video of
my meet up to that this is how it is as
a result there was a huge positive
response positive response in the lot of
people started coming without asking
questions also this article is now
getting shared by other organizer of my
sitting whenever a new member is joining
it so if you are getting questions like
this be ready will not hesitate go ahead
write such kind of stuff put it on your
website your comity or because you never
know what kind of questions people are
coming with sponsors the most
interesting and important part of the
community we were not lucky for one
whole year we were running our meetups
by our own salary we used to pay for our
food our venue and we used to do the
meetups free of cost I didn't
have any experience at how I can reach
to sponsors I have no experience how I
can pitch them so I was not able to do
anything as well as in Delhi NCR
companies were not open for our non
branding non branded meetups or
community so the struggle was very real
at the time but luckily we got our first
sponsor that was a co-working space we
used to have our meetups here again the
same question what are you doing on
weekend there are you trying to hire
people do you haven't have any product
and sort of questions I was explaining
the owner of that co-working space and
they got in they were very happy and
what they offered us is you can utilize
our space free of cost and till date we
do I make ups there
so this is how we got our first venue
sponsor after that we got Microsoft as
our official corporate sponsor that was
a big break for us because Microsoft was
our first corporate sponsor they came up
with their venue food as well as
speakers and this is how we become we
have two categories or sponsor first is
food and menu and second is knowledge
partners where companies can send their
speakers to share knowledge one thing I
learned out of that sponsors are our
two-way relationship for me it is not
that if someone is sponsoring I will
just say yes I first evaluate that what
value they can add what value I can add
to them only then I say yes because
Jesus Navas is a community dedicated to
developers only so whenever if some
sponsor is just coming to sell something
or pitch something I just say move
unless and until it is something
valuable same with me if I am NOT able
to add any value to their company my
committee I say no so if you are going
to pick any sponsor please pick it very
carefully it is very important because
your members are very smart they will
understand that you have a paid sponsor
standing on the stage so you need to be
very careful I have said no to many
sponsors and I don't regret because I
know because of that
there is trust of my members few of the
sponsors we have are here out of that
Amazon egghead native scripts are
knowledge partner the good thing is we
keep doing lot of swags and because of
the swags people also get hooked to us
but it is not that every time they will
get swags this is the most tricky part
this is a surprise factor so if you are
coming to our meetup for example this
month you might get or you might not get
so this was always a surprise vector
collaborations collaborations is very
very important if you try to survive on
your own you will not fall long way you
need to learn from and with others it's
very important so when I started jazz
lovers after few months there were a lot
of people who used to attend our
workshop from first event and one day we
just bounce the idea are you interested
in learning something apart from their
Penzias and they said yes so we did an
IOT workshop and we got very good
response and I asked for the feedback
and they shared that now they feel very
happy because they have a skill apart
from their primary skill and they
enjoyed it and after that I realized
that yes it is important if I am a web
developer but I know like Android or iOS
is a fun you never know what will become
your hobby so I started in collaboration
with other committees and other
technologies and this helped my members
as well as me too as an organizer
because I learned what other organizers
are doing how they are way so I was
missing the biggest thing which is code
of conduct in my community while I was
doing a collaboration one of the
organizer actually shared with me that
you should have a code of conduct in
your committee because if you are if
someone is actually troubling you that
code of conduct can help you a lot and
then I said oh yes I forgot and this is
how I learned it by doing the
collaboration by meeting new organizers
so please if you are getting an
opportunity of doing collaboration do it
I am not scared lot of people come to me
and say you are a Chavez script
why are you doing meetup on XYZ I was
like because my members are asking for
it they wanted to learn and grow and so
I feedback always always ask for the
feedback because this is what I believe
feedbacks are your next steps if chairs
lovers is able to come through three
years it just because of we worked on
feedbacks if I am not getting a feedback
I feel that I am doing literally a very
wrong thing
developers are very shy specially in
Delhi and yeah it's very hard to get
feedback it's very hard to make them
talk so the first thing is language most
of the developers there assume that
their English is not gold and all that
so what as an organizer and speaker we
do is we make them comfortable in
speaking in native language it's fine if
you don't know English but we know your
native language and we actually promote
that it lets have a meet-up on the knee
in native language and when I asked for
the feedback I never asked feedback in
direct questions I always asked with
options so that at least the audience
will reply like did you like the
location yes or no would you like to
have the repeat event here yes or no how
was the food and so it and I always
close my session with the open thread if
you like this event please go out spread
the word on social media in your with
your friends in your company if you
don't please write me a personal email I
will look into it so you need to ask for
the feedback because feedback will help
you a lot improve as a result initially
when people were not open to write their
feedback on the meetup page event page
now they are openly going and sharing
the feedback on social media so this is
how you have to do it there would be the
moment when people are not doing it but
you need to push them and just keep
doing it what failed it's not like this
that everything is working first time
nope lot of lot of things lot of places
where I failed my ideas fail and lot of
things failed few of the things as lot
of meetups so
the idea was to have a lot of meter we
will have a lot of members joining us
and as a result we were doing three to
four meetups in a month which was so
hectic for the organizers as well as for
the members because everyone was busy
Monday to Friday in their job and Sunday
coming for the codelab
is very tricky so did this design wave
work so what we started doing is one
Meetup one cinnamon that's it and that
actually helped us a lot
now people were started looking for that
one meetup in a month to meet us
building the best team running our
community at such scale is very tricky
it was just me and my co organizer and
we used to have our full-time job also
so it's like a crazy job we were doing
two jobs I was not able to build the
team because we were looking for the
best people and as a result I was just
ending up following with them but after
a few months I realized I should look
for the self-motivated people who
understand what it takes to be a part of
the committee and as a result now we
have five people who helped me in social
media graphics and everything they take
care of each and everything and I don't
need to do any follow up and anything
they just know because they are
self-motivated and they know what they
want to do what's happened slack this is
the most asked question please have a
whatsapp or slack rope
I left lot of whatsapp group just
because people used to put all the code
on the whatsapp and as a result I got
annoyed and I have to drop that group
slag group it just get died you need to
be there every time doing moderation
breaking the eyes and everything so it
was like I am running offline committee
and I am also maintaining online
community and every time I have to push
the discussion from one place to another
and I was like this is not done this is
what you asked you need to run it I
can't be the organized main person
behind that so these two things doesn't
work for me so I stopped and I kept
everything on my platform which is
Meetup but the second problem where is
diversity in one of the meter we have
few females and then there is only me
then there are few
females and then again it's only me so I
was like in shock because I was hoping
that a lot of females will come because
a female is the front face she is
running the show she knows all the pain
she has taken care of everything but
nope this is not happening
and then I start thinking it is because
the problem I am facing with my family
my friends my society for them it is
much harder because they are just coming
to attend an event they can't explain to
their family why they are going on
weekend for eight hours at the XY place
just to learn something because in
delhi-ncr the most of the parents like
my parents they are like you have a full
set of job you are getting the salary
that's it don't thing beyond that do not
even think of doing something else so I
knew that trouble and I was like what I
can do about this how can I make sure
that those females are actually knowing
that something is happening they are
learning and everything meanwhile if
there was a girl who attended one of my
workshop progressive web app she reached
me on social media she said she has some
doubts and then I started helping her in
making blogs writing writing blogs
making videos and everything and as a
result after three months I get to know
that she actually built her first
progressive web app she presented a
hundred in college our professor lined
it she give a workshop at her college
level then I did and she also got an
internship because of that and and she
actually messaged me that because you
helped and guided me all through on
social media by doing videos blogging in
everything I'm able to do it and then I
realize it's fine if you are not coming
to my Meetup but for me it would be very
wrong if you are reaching me for asking
help online and I'm not doing it I keep
getting a lot of messages from people I
have never met and I'm sure every
speaker get this that hey you don't know
me you never make me but I have seen
your video I have read your blog it
inspired me to do this that and actually
that is what the community is and that
is how Jesus lever is doing we are not
helping everyone who is space because
because I am a girl sorry
and everyone who is reaching me on
social media on my email that we need
help and I'm helping them out so guys if
you are a community organizer if you are
planning to run a committee it's not
just they came into a room and they vent
your relation is done it's also about
support and mentoring them after that
please do it it will make a lot of lot
of difference as a result meetup on
which my group is they actually invited
me two months ago in their headquarters
in here to share my story as well as
they also covered my story that how I do
a meet-up so good thing also happened
with me I hope this helped you a lot too
if your organizer you get some tips if
you are planning you get an idea how you
have to do it the important part is
never ever give up this is my mantra you
never know who you are inspiring guys
you literally never know I when I
started I didn't knew I am actually
helping so many people but when I get
messages I feel so happy that a small
idea of running our meetup now its reach
to this level thank you guys